what's going on everyone welcome back to
anime uproar I am your host Axel beats
and one of the coolest parts of Chainsaw
man is easily the Devils there are so
many and they vary so much that breathes
constant life into the series within
chainsaw man part 1 alone there is well
over 40 Devils that fill out the 97
chapters so you're basically getting a
new one every other chapter and I just
think that's pretty rad So today we're
going to be talking about all the Devils
which show up in part one there are
obviously going to be spoilers ahead for
the anime only but in reality there's
only one or two big spoilers so I'll
leave those for last and I'll give you a
warning before we get there otherwise
I'll just be talking more about what the
Devils look like and what they're
generally able to do of course if you
enjoy chainsaw man content and you want
to see more on the channel remember to
leave a like And subscribe for more
content in the future but with all that
out of the way let's start things off
with the marshmallow devil so luckily
for my sanity while making this video
while there are a ton of different
devils in the series many of them don't
really get a lot of screen time and
there isn't much to say about them but
this is a good time for me to mention
how Devils work as the marshmallow devil
is actually a pretty good example all
Devil's strength comes from the fear
that Humanity Associates with that
identity the more scary that something
is the more powerful the associated
devil named after that fear is as a
result and as marshmallows aren't
particularly frightening the marshmallow
devil is pretty weak only being
represented as a puffy white ooze in
general though there are a kind of rule
of thumb set of abilities for all Devils
firstly they are all nearly Immortal
while they can die after actually
passing they will go to hell and if they
die there they'll be reincarnated on
Earth however once they do this they'll
have an entirely different personality
all Devils can heal by consuming blood
and their physical strength is
proportional to the concept that they
embody almost always is being stronger
than humans by default though so again
something like a lion devil would be
crazy strong while a marshmallow devil
not that powerful the marshmallow devil
itself is the first devil that denji
actually kills with the help of pochita
and ultimately leads to his survival as
devil hunting became denji's most
lucrative source of income for paying
off his father's debt the Tomato devil
looks much more terrifying which leads
me to believe that dislikes can also
lean into a devil's strength and not
just specifically fear because while not
many people are afraid of tomatoes many
people don't like them and rather than
just being a small red blob the Tomato
Devil is a huge Red Tomato covered with
massive eyes a vertical mouth and a set
of eight human arms which act as legs
that said while it looks more terrifying
it still isn't particularly strong so
disdain and dislikes might lean into how
a devil looks while fear is where it
gets its power that's my understanding
the Tomato devil is the first devil that
denji kills in the story that we follow
but he's eliminated pretty quickly and
we don't see his power being used it is
mentioned though that the Tomato devil
can regenerate itself so long as one of
its seeds survives and for the last of
denji's Firsts the zombie devil is the
first devil that denji defeats as
chainsaw man the first time that we hear
about the zombie devil the Yakuza that
denji is indebted to offered themselves
as slaves to him in exchange for his
power the zombie Devil Himself looks
like a massive grafted together corpse
he is a face planted on the chest of an
appendageless torso being supported by
his entrails the zombie Devil's main
ability is to turn people into zombies
that it gets total control over
something to note is that if someone
were to gain control over the zombie
devil or any other devil they would also
be able to use their abilities the
muscle devil was skipped over in the
anime but it was actually a pretty cool
one when makima brings Genji to the
ramen shop in the manga denji must go to
deal with the muscle devil before he's
able to eat this devil kind of sets up
an angler fish-like trap for denji his
abilities allow him to control and
manipulate any muscles he touches so he
controls a young girl to use her as bait
and lure denji in to make him lower his
guard the muscle devil originally
appears as a small snake-like dude
however he's able to massively increase
in size and strength by expanding his
muscles as I mentioned he can completely
manipulate any muscles he comes in
contact with and can even shred or break
apart those muscles on someone else
continuing on with these early Devils we
have the sea cucumber devil this was a
large pink gooey sea cucumber that had
dozens of human fingers sprouting out of
it as well as a single human skull
towards the top we don't get to see a
whole lot of this devil as power one
shot sitting sprays it all over the
street but we do see that the civilians
on site were struggling to deal with it
the bat devil is the one who's stole
meowy from power and is one of few
recurring Devils that we get in the
series he appears as a massive humanoid
bat with sharp teeth to Crunch down on
people and wings that he's able to fly
with this devil seems to have a
particularly sensitive sense of taste as
he is picky about who and what he eats
being disgusted by denji and preferring
to eat children something which might
also be tied to his heightened sense of
smell which allows him to pinpoint
humans at different points of the city
aside from flight the other big ability
that this devil has is that he can turn
his mouth into a cannon which fires
powerful bursts of air strong enough to
destroy buildings and of course the bat
devil was dating the leech devil which
is just truly a blood-sucking match made
in heaven the leech devil Fam I'm gonna
be real I don't think I can show this on
screen so instead just you're gonna have
normal leeches but this was a long leech
with human legs and just like too many
booba and not the good kind of after
denji kills the bat devil the leech
devil arrived enraged although she does
offer to spare him because he's cute
this devil didn't seem to have any
particular special abilities other than
being able to stab her tongue through
dengie's chest and it's probably safe to
say she has some blood-sucking abilities
as well as she is a leech on the fox
devil while we don't know the full
appearance of this devil we do know that
its head and arms are covered in large
monstrous eyes this devil has contracts
with several humans offering to work for
them in exchange for their flesh on each
use Aki Nomo Nakamura and hirokazu all
have been shown to work with this devil
while the fox devil resides in Kyoto the
devil Hunters are able to summon parts
of its body to nearly any location to
attack and devour other Devils that said
he doesn't like to eat hybrid Devils
because they taste bad the fish devil is
one we don't know a lot about in terms
of abilities or personality as we only
get a look at it after Aki has killed it
and removed part of the gun devil from
it the fish devil is the size of a large
shark with razor-sharp teeth two Tail
Fins and six insect-like legs so it's
not exactly the prettiest of the Devils
the first devil that really creeped me
out in the series though is easily The
Eternity devil this devil forms around
its tiny core and has several eyes and
mouths on either side of it most iconic
ability of The Eternity devil is to
produce a pocket demand within its
stomach trapping denji and his group on
one floor of a hotel which is infinitely
looped on top of this time is stopped
within this Dimension and The Eternity
devil is able to produce a body which
can keep growing over time as it
produces endless waves of Flesh and
appendages much like denji Katana man is
a hybrid except with the katana devil
that said this is the only way that we
know the katana devil exists we don't
actually know much about the devil
itself and it's kind of like guessing
what pochita was like based on denji's
transformation on that note the same can
be said about several other hybrids
throughout the series including the bomb
devil the crossbow devil the long sword
devil the flamethrower devil the spear
devil and the whip devil as they only
appear in hybrid forms when summoned the
cursed devil appears as a skeleton with
two skulls one looking human and the
other looking demonic it has large
clawed hands and an expanded rib cage
which can be used to surround and hold
people in place once the victim is
locked in the skulls will clamp down on
them biting their shoulder and neck
while their claws Crush their arms to
summon this devil someone must be
stabbed with a cursed Spike three times
at which point the devil will appear and
kill the victim that said we later see
this needing four stabs so it does
differ depending on the contract the
cursed devil has with each person the
cost of summoning the cursed devil is to
offer up your lifespan or the use of
specific body parts rather than flesh
like it was with the fox devil and with
that we are definitely into the stage of
the story where Devils just become more
and more grotesque and terrifying as we
go the snake Devil is a huge snake with
a face made up of dozens of interlocking
arms and hands where the teeth should be
this devil has a contract with akane and
for the price of four fingernails she
can summon it to devour her enemies
completely or she can have the devil
spit up that enemy and release them
which will cause her nose to bleed it's
pretty worth it though as once released
the victim will be completely healed and
forced to fight for the user the snake
Devil's tale can also be summoned by the
movement of the user's hands the ghost
devil is creepy as hell it has this
creepy withered old woman's face with a
sewn shut mouth and eyes this dirty
disheveled hair and a body made of
flowers with a bunch of arms being used
as her legs almost similar to the Tomato
devil as this is the embodiment of the
fear of ghosts it's pretty powerful
interestingly enough though this devil
also demonstrates fear of others as the
ghost devil is afraid of katana man at
first and needs to be bribed into
fighting the ghost devil had a contract
with himano for the price of her eye
which allowed her to use a ghostly hand
which is intangible for others however
the hand itself is able to interact with
them so for example she is able to choke
power but Power can't grab it to
retaliate even though is also able to
give up more of her body to gain access
to more of the ghost devil for a short
time finally this Devil's eyes are sewn
shut so it is unable to see instead it
perceives the World Around It by sensing
fear unfortunately meaning that it can't
see anyone who isn't afraid of her or
just doesn't fear dying the future devil
embodying the fear of the future is
obviously the one I'm most afraid of
this devil looks like a tree sprouting
from the ground and growing into a
scarecrow shape with arms spread out and
a head that looks like it has antlers on
it its chest has a chasm in the center
of it with a giant eyeball in it as well
definitely adding to the creepiness but
if someone sticks their head into that
hole the devil is able to read that
person's future that said this dude is
kind of awesome and hilarious he speaks
with this very playful and fun way which
kind of counteracts how terrifying he is
he's always bragging about how he has
the best future and that just makes him
a really enjoyable character in a weird
way the featured devil was captured by
the devil hunters and made contract x
with two of them one offering up half of
his life while the other gave up his
eyes sense of taste and sense of smell
it later makes a deal with Aki for the
low price of being able to live in his
right eye so that he can experience
Aki's future firsthand next up is the
angel devil someone who is pretty
interesting as they're one of the only
Devils who isn't directly hostile to
humans although he still does want them
to die in pain so you know take the good
with the bad he considers himself a
devil first and an Angel Second even if
physically he does look much more
Angelic seeming like a normal dude with
angel wings and a Halo and no real
definable devil traits the angel devil
is able to absorb people's lifespan by
touching them he is fast enough to react
to bullets and his wings are strong
enough to deflect those bullets he can
also turn siphoned lifespan into weapons
with varying strength depending on how
much energy he puts into them all this
making him one of the cooler down levels
despite his simplicity
devil is kinda horrifying looking like a
normal woman aside from her eight fleshy
legs and a zipper that divides her face
in half while she works as a devil
Hunter she actively kills people who
look at her the wrong way and shows no
emotions in almost any situation spider
devil is able to dive into the ground
and pop up anywhere she'd like but more
interestingly is her ability to unzip
her body to summon makima directly to
her raising the question if she can
summon anyone this way or only makima
the typhoon devil looks like a giant
with an exposed brain that has a tornado
of brain matter swirling around them
this devil can produce storms strong
enough to destroy buildings and send
cars flying by spinning their guts
around them and can also produce
rainstorms finally this devil is also
able to communicate through swirling
water the pig devil is one we see very
little of it's a large Pig with two
pairs of eyes the first looking fairly
normal and the second being small ones
about snow you don't get much else other
than its appearance as it's already died
before appearing on screen the mold
devil is another we don't see physically
however we do see two contracts being
made with it the contract holders can
bite their hands until they bleed point
at something living and create mold that
grows inside of them to cause internal
bleeding nothing else is really known
about the mold devil the grape devil in
line with the marshmallow and tomato
devil is yet another weak devil this one
looking like a bunch of eyes connected
with intestines rather than grapevines
and honestly I'm kind of glad we don't
see more of this one the skin devil you
know for people who are afraid of skin
has only been seen through contracts if
the contract holder touches a corpse
they are able to shapeshift into the
appearance of that person the dull devil
spawned from the fear of anyone who
slept at their grandmother's house as a
child and had 40 of these things staring
at them all night is the devil that has
a contract with Santa Clause we don't
know the price of this contract however
Santa Claus is able to create dolls that
follow her orders this will actually
spread through contact with these dolls
by anyone that they come across with the
exception of fiends and Devils we've
seen these dolls turning one of their
arms into blades but Santa Claus needs
to keep close to them in order to keep
control over them the claw needle and
knife devils are more that we only see
through contracts however even here we
don't really get to see the specifics of
their contracts being used the octopus
devil has only been seen through the use
of its contract however we have seen it
having an absolutely huge tentacle
implying that it itself is pretty
massive we don't know the price of using
this devil but the contract holder is
able to summon parts of the octopus's
body and make ink clouds to distract any
attackers back to some of the big bad
devils in the series we have the hell
devil a flaming zombie-like Centaur with
splinters shooting off of its arm arms
and a soldier's helmet the hell devil in
exchange for sacrificing a few lives can
send everyone in an area directly to
Hell manifesting an insanely large
six-fingered hand that descends from the
sky and takes hold of those being sent
to Hell people can also game over
themselves in order to summon the hell
devil directly to the Earth but of
course once people are in Hell they'll
come across a devil embodying one of the
Primal fears
Darkness devil a horrific amalgamation
of body parts and Bones forming Wings in
a totem pole like head where they'll
find a skull with horns reaching out of
its eye sockets instead of legs this
devil has two complete zombified human
bodies and as this devil represents a
primal fear we know that it's never
experienced death because it is so
powerful this devil can manipulate
Darkness freely appearing anywhere it
wants to within that darkness and
becoming unable to take damage while it
is in that Darkness it can turn into and
produce Darkness manifest bodies within
that darkness and conjure a blade of
darkness which it can control with its
mind after being struck by that Blade
the bells that are on that sword will
cause hemorrhaging when they ring on top
of that the darkness devil can stare at
anyone be they devil or human and they
will start hemorrhaging until they bleed
to death it can damage anyone simply by
pointing at them he is strong enough to
mangle and twist makima's arm and can
destroy severed body parts just by
chanting we see him forming a contract
and giving the user a piece of his flesh
which significantly powers that person
up allowing them to transform and become
invulnerable in darkness this is easily
one of the strongest and scariest Devils
we see but God damn is he cool the stone
devil looks like a gargoyle with a more
demonic looking head it has the
interesting ability to petrify anything
it touches and if a contract is created
with it and the user is standing in a
special cliff on the floor they're able
to form a ring with their hands blow
through it and petrify anyone in front
of them there does seem to be a limit on
how many people it's able to do this for
at once though this devil is also
apparently very fickle with its
contracts though we have yet to see the
actual price that people need to pay to
use it the gun devil probably one of the
most visually terrifying on this list
and by far the largest that we've seen
is the devil that can cause the most
large-scale destruction alone and in the
quickest time this devil has a torso
made up of countless screaming skulls
which branch off into massive arms made
of amalgamations of guns his head is a
large skull with Jagged teeth and a
revolver Barrel standing out of its
front while his back is covered in more
firearms and where his legs should be
are these long magazines of bullets
dangling below him and I feel like I'm
really not selling just how big this guy
is but the rifles that make up his arms
are the size of buildings and this is
just his 20 form this devil first
appeared in America but then flew to
Japan where over a period of 26 seconds
it killed nearly 60 000 people in just
the five minutes that it was around
total it killed just over 1.2 million
before disappearing this action was so
horrific that it led not only to the
fear of guns increasing but the fear of
devils in general making all Devils more
powerful by proxy after being taken down
by some unknown force it was split
between the major world towers and
fragments of the gun would be found all
over the world as Devils would consume
it to become more powerful and violent
themselves the gun devil moves so fast
that we'll see parts of its flesh
burning off as it's traveling however it
does regenerate itself so this is pretty
mitigated it can fire bullets through
the heads of every adult man within a
thousand meters every child within 1500
meters and the Heart of every living
thing born in January February March May
June August September November and
December within a thousand meters
meaning that this is the only time that
your horoscope sign has actually
mattered the punishment devil is yet
another which is absolutely terrifying
this cluster of conjoined severed and
disjointed human bodies each carrying a
different weapon while the outermost
bodies have extra arms to kind of form
this mouth around the rest of them there
are plenty of devils that are made of
these like blobs of human bodies but not
many of them have this weird level of
incompleteness for each body let's just
adds to the air of creepiness that this
thing has however outside of how
terrifying it is we don't really know
much about this devil at all we know it
had at least two contracts in the past
but we don't know what it allowed for
the people or what the price that was
associated with these contracts were in
terms of power all we know is that it's
strong enough to battle with the gun
devil however that doesn't mean much
considering all of the other Devils that
it teamed up with in that fight the
Mantis devil is one that we only see
partially similar to the octopus devil
all we see is one large mantis sickle
erupting from the ground attempting to
slash at Genji in power despite this it
doesn't seem too powerful on its own as
they fend it off pretty easily this
devil has a contract with two unnamed
Public Safety devil hunters and its
sickle is summoned by these contract
holders clapping their hands and of
course it is unclear if there's any more
cost to summoning this devil or if it
has other forms and before we get into
the big two spoilers we also know that
specific devil exist as we meet their
fiends throughout the series these being
the blood devil the violence devil the
shark devil and a few unknown Devils
which reflect Cosmo pinksty long and
sukihagi anyways big spoiler time last
warning three two one makima is the
control devil embodying the fear of
control and Conquest in terms of how she
looks akima is designed to look exactly
like best girl for some reason typically
seeming like just a pretty normal human
aside from her yellow eyes which have
circles inside of them akima looks down
on everything and everyone around her
with their only really being a few real
exceptions with the big one being the
idea of Chainsaw man or more
specifically what he represents she
often looks at others the same way that
an owner looks at their dogs and outside
of this she's able to manipulate and
scare everyone around her into doing
exactly what she wants them to do this
manipulative personality in combination
with her strengths and abilities makes
her easily one of the strongest devils
in the series of all of her abilities
the control Devil's most powerful is
actually a pretty subtle one rather than
something flashy makima is just able to
force anyone that she sees as inferior
to herself into making contracts with
her and if you think about all the
prices that we've seen for contracts and
the terms we've seen attached to them in
most cases people are typically willing
to offer parts of their body in exchange
for the power that those Devils have to
offer them it's a system that is in most
cases based on Fair exchange however
makima breaks this rule she doesn't need
to offer anything in return or at least
not anything of real value like the
zombie devil makima could trade for a
person's entire bodily autonomy in a
contract with her offering them nothing
in return as she could force them to
agree arguably one of the most important
examples of a contract she has made is
with the Prime Minister of Japan in
exchange for working for him something
which also just in general benefits her
the Prime Minister offers up his people
as payment and because of this if nakima
is fatally attacked an illness will be
passed to a random citizen of Japan so
that she can revive herself in their
stead on top of this anyone who is
controlled by makima will lose memories
of the moments leading up to that
control as well as anything they did
while control and again this works on
anyone she sees inferior to her this
could be humans Devils hybrids fiends
animals or even corpses this control
covers their actions their thoughts and
can even extend to her borrowing their
senses for example being able to hear
through rats and birds and eavesdrop on
conversations or she can just Clump
together these beings and transform them
into herself for instant travel and
while his control can be broken it's
it's very rare that we see it happening
finally makima likes the darkness devil
can emit an invisible force through her
fingers with devastating power this can
be over a large distance if she has
sacrifices and a good amount of setup or
she can do it in close range pretty
freely by pointing at someone and saying
bang something strong enough to
eviscerate someone's body instantly and
finally let's talk about the chainsaw
devil our first exposure to the chainsaw
devil sees him as an absolutely good boy
with a chainsaw extending from his face
he becomes denji's partner and together
they fight against Devils this is a
near-death State for the chainsaw devil
and only exists as a result of a massive
battle happening just before the series
began his first contract was a trade
with denji for his blood and in return
the chainsaw devil or pochita would help
him pay off his debt The second contract
they form involves pochuda becoming
denji's heart in exchange for watching
denji's Dreams Come true now notably I
skipped over details for most of the
other hybrids that we talked about and
I'm probably going to do the same with
chainsaw man because in his chainsaw
form he's really just a dude who can
grow a few chainsaws on his arms and
face as well as like the normal devil
strength and regeneration but what we do
need to talk about is his normal form
which is this large forearmed man with
chainsaws on each arm and one coming out
of his head but this form extending
intestines from his stomach and wrapping
around his neck like a scarf and just
like in the hybrid form the chainsaw
devil can use his chains to entrap or
tangle up enemies as well as using them
to get around similar to a mini version
of Spider-Man's webs the chainsaw devil
is one of the strongest that the story
has to offer he's called the devil that
other Devils fear most and is second
only to the primordial devils like the
darkness devil but while he is deadly
and extremely strong this isn't what
makes him so powerful the reason that
all Devils fear him is that he has the
ability to erase them if the chainsaw
devil consumes another devil their name
Will vanish from the minds of people on
the planet and since a devil's power is
based on the fear that they represent if
no one remembers that they exist they
lose all strength and vanish themselves
that said we do see one devil that he
consumed returning to life but that's
more of a chainsaw man part 2 issue some
Concepts or Devils which have vanished
include World War II Nazis AIDS nuclear
weapons and things of that variety and
even eating part of a devil can have an
effect for example he consumed part of
the war devil and while the concept of
War remained in the public mind no war
had been waged since then on top of that
if chainsaw man happens to vomit up one
of these Concepts those will return to
the world as well a set of powers
obviously making him extremely important
to the path Humanity takes going forward
and with that out of the way okay that's
all of them every devil mentioned or
seen in the entirety of Chainsaw man
part 1 covering up to chapter 97 of the
manga and while there are several
standouts I think that the darkness
devil the control devil and The Eternity
devil are easily my favorites they just
have such unique and interesting
storytelling devices tied to their
characters while also being pretty
terrifying in their own rights but which
ones are your favorites and which ones
would you form a contract with let me
know in the comments down below as well
as suggesting future videos that we can
make for chainsaw man content that you
would like to see if you enjoyed this
video though remember to leave a like to
let us know to keep more content like
this coming as well as subscribing so
you can be notified when we post
something so you'll never miss a future
upload or if you would like to support
me directly you can check out my own
channel axelbeats where I've been doing
a villain analysis series and even did a
video talking about the philosophy
behind denji's character in chainsaw man
I think you'd really enjoy those so if
you're looking for for something a bit
different you could definitely check
those out with that being said though
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time I hope you all stay
excellent